And finally, there's a follow up process. The author of the artifact should
report to the moderator the results of the reworked process.
The moderator should confirm that the fixes have been properly implemented.
Also, the moderator should collect data on the review itself.
Such as the number and types of defects detected, the number of participants,
and the total time spent reviewing. This data should be recorded and
saved, so that the process of reviewing itself is being reviewed and, and
possibly improved if it, if it can be.
Finally, the moderator should suggest these improvements to the review process.
And, take them up with, the organizational, quality people, so
that o, over time, the effectiveness of the review process itself can improved.